Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous
et ravie de vous retrouver
pour "Politiques, à table"
comme chaque semaine sur LCP
autour d'un plat
et surtout d'un invité.
Aujourd'hui,
nous recevons Sophia Aram.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être avec nous.
-Merci à vous,
je suis ravie.
-Avec nous
pour cette émission,
Jean-Pierre Montanay. Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes humoriste,
comédienne, chroniqueuse
sur France Inter depuis 2008,
on peut vous écouter
le lundi matin,
à 8h55, il faut être
déjà bien réveillé
parce qu'avec vous,
ça fuse dans tous les coins.
Un festival de vannes
où le RN est rhabillé
en majesté et l'islam radical,
votre cible
privilégiée.
On peut vous voir
au théâtre, en ce moment,
au Studio des Champs-Elysées
pour "Le monde d'après" où vous
recherchez une gauche perdue,
vous critiquez
une gauche complaisante,
abritée derrière sa bien-pensance.
Vous avez
des origines marocaines.
Vous avez été élevée
à Trappes. Symbole d'intégration
réussie jusque dans l'assiette ?
Ou, parce que vous venez
d'une grande fratrie
où les deux parents bossent,
on n'a pas le temps
de se prendre la tête avec le menu ?
Alors on a fait simple.
-Simplissime, je dirais.
-Des pâtes à la sauce tomate
et un moelleux au chocolat
en dessert.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
peut-on rire et manger ?
Nous vous emmenons
au Paname Art Café
pour une série de stand-up.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
le succès
de la cuisine végétarienne.
Les restaurants
nous font saliver
avec des recettes
au goût de viande,
sans viande.
Reportage à suivre.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite :
Cuisine et confidences.
-En vous invitant
à "Politiques, à table",
c'est le mot "politique"
qui a fait tilt chez vous
plus qu'"à table". Vous êtes
politique avec des convictions :
"un cap", "laïcarde",
"républicaine", "de gauche",
alors que lorsqu'on passe à table,
vous n'avez pas de repères,
étonnant de la part
d'une fille de chef cuisinier.
Enfant,
vous aviez une passion
pour le beurre.
On aurait pu penser
à un plat normand,
mais pas du tout,
le beurre est passé
à la trappe.
-Joli, Jean-Pierre !
-Votre plat favori, c'est le rfissa,
une recette marocaine
avec des lentilles
et du poulet. Du poulet ?
J'ai lu que vous étiez végétarienne.
Allez comprendre.
Votre choix s'est porté
sur des pâtes à la tomate, basique.
Je me suis dit que c'était histoire
de rendre hommage à l'Italie,
votre troisième patrie culinaire
après la France et le Maroc,
mais...
Je découvre que vous n'avez jamais
mis les pieds
dans la botte !
A table, vous êtes
une énigme et, selon vous,
une jouisseuse.
Dites-moi, pourquoi ces pâtes
à la tomate sont si glamours
pour vous ?
-Alors, je suis allée
en Italie.
-Ah, depuis !
-J'y suis allée souvent.
Mais si ! On vous a menti !
-J'ai lu...
-Quelqu'un de mal informé.
-Ou c'est un vieux papier.
-Non !
-Fake news !
J'aime beaucoup l'Italie.
Je connais pas le sud,
je connais le nord,
mais j'aime la cuisine sarde.
J'aime l'Italie.
Pourquoi j'ai choisi les pâtes ?
C'est la question ?
-Oui, pourquoi ?
-Une jouisseuse
à table choisit ça ?
-C'est le plat le plus rassurant,
pour moi.
Je trouve ça sécurisant.
-C'est un doudou.
-Ouais. Vraiment !
-A table, c'est un moment
qui vous rassure, un moment
privilégié, pour vous ?
-Ca peut.
C'est plein de choses.
Parfois, j'ai pas le temps,
je mange par nécessité.
Mais quand j'arrive quelque part
et que je me dis :
"Qu'est-ce que je veux manger
pour être bien ?"
C'est ça.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous rassure
dans les pâtes à la tomate ?
-C'est tellement bon.
-Ca dépend.
-Vous aimez pas ça ?
-Si, j'adore !
-Il a l'air déçu.
Vous auriez préféré
que je choisisse autre chose, mais
je peux faire une semaine à manger
tous les midis
des pâtes à la tomate,
ça me lassera pas.
-On va goûter.
Vous nous direz
si elles sont comme vos pâtes.
-J'ai une expertise.
-C'est ça.
-C'est pas les miennes plus
que celles que je mange
au restaurant
ou qu'on me fait.
Je suis pas
une excellente cuisinière, non plus.
-On va en parler.
-Elle est maligne, Sophia Aram.
Elle a un pull noir.
Moi, une chemise...
-Vous avez joué la chemise blanche.
Vous êtes joueur.
-Surtout que vous voulez
poser une question ?
-Je voulais savoir...
Déjà, elles sont bonnes ?
-Très bonnes.
Elles sont très bonnes.
On aurait aimé un peu de parmesan.
Je... Une...
Une petite critique ! Voilà.
-Comment vous les faites ?
-Alors...
-Parce qu'il y a
une recette, peut-être.
-Moi,
je mets beaucoup d'ail.
Beaucoup, beaucoup d'ail
parce que l'ail, c'est de l'amour.
Ouais, non, l'ail, j'aime bien
quand c'est relevé.
Je peux mettre
un peu de peperoncino.
-L'ail un peu confit ?
En chemise ?
-Non, non. On fait revenir l'ail
dans le...
-Donc c'est bien aillé.
-Oui,
dans l'huile d'olive
et les tomates... J'aime bien
la pulpe
de tomates cerises.
On trouve ça...
-C'est un peu plus
sucré ?
-Oui. Parce que le goût de sucre
dans la tomate retire l'acidité
et voilà,
on met un peu de bouillon
de l'eau des pâtes.
-Très bien.
A l'italienne ! Est-ce que vous
les faites revenir à la poêle ?
-Oui ! Evidemment,
vous m'avez prise
pour une débutante ?
-Une novice !
Al dente, c'est combien
de temps alors ?
-Ca dépend des pâtes.
Ca, c'est des pâtes fraîches,
donc que ça doit être
peu de cuisson,
mais quand on prend des pâtes
sèches, si c'est indiqué 13 minutes,
il faut mettre 11.
-Un petit peu moins.
Voilà.
-10 ou 11, ouais.
Pour les faire revenir un peu
dans la sauce.
-Brigitte m'a spoilé.
J'avais préparé...
-Pour faire les meilleures pâtes...
-Oui, mais alors...
-Elle a posé une question.
-Vous auriez pu dire des bêtises.
Je vais faire que répéter.
-Vraiment ?
-On va aller vite.
-J'aurais pris
des taglioni, parce que la sauce
peut se lover à l'intérieur
de ces gros tubes.
Pour les faire al dente,
elle a raison,
il faut ne pas respecter
le temps de cuisson
indiqué sur la boîte.
Garder l'eau de cuisson
parce qu'elle contient
de l'amidon des pâtes
et lorsqu'on la remettra,
ça fera un peu de liant.
Vous faites revenir
une gousse d'ail,
vous mettez vos pâtes,
des sauces tomate, des boîtes,
pas de tomates fraîches,
mauvaises
en France.
-Et pas l'hiver, surtout.
-Des tomates en boîte,
privilégiez les marques
italiennes, on trouve
des tomates qui sont bonnes
pour faire des pâtes à l'italienne
et à la fin, on remue tout.
Moi, je mets quelques feuilles
de basilic
et pour une touche gourmande,
je mets des petits copeaux
de scarmorza, la mozzarella
fumée.
Ca donne une petite touche.
C'est très bon.
-Merci, Jean-Pierre
pour cette très bonne recette.
-Elle connaît ses pâtes.
-Pour vous, c'est rassurant,
ces pâtes.
Ca veut dire que vous retrouvez
quasiment la même recette
partout où vous allez ?
Il y a peu de variantes
sur cette recette ?
-Il peut y en avoir
un tout petit peu,
mais c'est pas foufou,
c'est une base.
-On sait ce qu'on va manger.
Il y a de ça aussi.
-Je crois que c'est ça.
C'est en ça que c'est rassurant.
Il y a pas de...
de prise de risque
parce que j'imagine
que quand on va manger,
je dis n'importe quoi,
une blanquette de veau,
d'une maison à l'autre,
ce sera pas la même recette,
alors que des pâtes
à la sauce tomate
avec ou sans ail,
avec ou sans basilic...
-Y a peu de chances de se vautrer.
-Non.
-C'est votre nature,
la sécurité ?
-J'en prends, mais au niveau
de l'assiette...
Il faut pouvoir...
-On se rassure.
-On en prend assez ailleurs
pour avoir des lieux
dans lesquels on est confort.
-Vous avez fait ramener des pâtes
à la tomate trop cuites ?
Vous ne vous permettez pas ça ?
-Non, je fais pas ça.
-J'avais des amis italiens
qui faisaient ça.
Trop cuites, alors ils les faisaient
ramener en cuisine.
-J'avais une belle-mère
qui n'aimait pas
les pâtes al dente.
On se grugeait
l'une et l'autre sur le chrono.
Elle,
elle mettait 13 minutes.
Moi, je mettais 9.
L'une passait derrière l'autre
pour changer
le chrono.
On était vraiment en conflit.
-Al dente, c'est presque un peu dur
pour nous,
pour nous Français.
C'est un peu,
un petit peu,
un petit peu...
-Trop al dente,
ça peut être gênant,
mais c'est meilleur
pour la santé.
Moins les pâtes sont cuites,
mieux on digère le gluten
responsable d'intolérances.
Il vaut mieux les manger
le moins cuites possible.
-Je bois
vos paroles.
Je suis ravie.
J'aime bien quand elles sont
pas trop cuites.
-Vous aimez cuisiner
ou pas ?
-Pas tellement.
-Ah mince !
-Mince alors !
Ouais, fille de cuisinier,
en fait,
ça me...
-Votre père ne vous a rien transmis.
-J'adorais être en cuisine
avec lui.
-Ses pâtes ?
-J'étais toujours dans la cuisine
à le regarder faire,
je trouvais ça merveilleux.
J'ai du mal à stabiliser
des recettes,
pour tout vous dire.
Je vais réussir
un truc
et la fois d'après, je vais
me lancer et ça va être décevant,
ça va être moins bien
et donc, ça me...
Voilà, je...
Je suis très déçue.
-Vous suivez pas bien
la recette ?
-Jamais.
-Ah ben oui !
-Je sais,
je suis trop indisciplinée pour ça,
je crois.
La cuisine et la pâtisserie
encore plus, c'est...
Il faut vraiment être sérieux,
rigoureux.
Moi, je suis un peu plus
fantaisiste.
J'aime bien changer un ingrédient
par un autre. "Tiens,
"y a pas de ça,
je vais mettre autre chose."
-A l'arrivée, c'est mauvais ?
Complètement raté ?
-Complètement raté. J'ai eu...
Il y a eu des drames.
Oui, oui.
J'ai des copains
qui sont venus
dîner...
-Ils reviennent plus ?
-Ils préfèrent
commander des pizzas.
C'est plus rassurant.
Il y a eu des vrais ratés.
-Votre homme
cuisine aussi.
C'est lui, le leader ?
-Il est très fort à table ?
-Il est plutôt fort,
de plus en plus.
Il y a eu...
Pareil, on part de très loin.
Il était vraiment mauvais, mais...
Comme je suis amoureuse,
je l'ai laissé faire,
et j'ai dit :
"C'est intéressant..."
Petit à petit...
Le confinement a aidé.
Ottolenghi aussi.
Les livres qu'on a reçus...
Ottolenghi, c'est merveilleux
pour cuisiner les légumes.
-Dingue, son succès.
-Oui !
-Il n'y a pas un invité
qui ne nous en parle pas.
-Ouais, mais c'est bon.
-C'est simple.
-"Simple",
c'est le titre du livre.
-"Jérusalem", aussi.
-Les recettes sont dures.
Il y a pas mal d'ingrédients.
-Ouais, mais après,
c'est la place
que prennent les légumes
dans la cuisine grâce à Ottolenghi.
Le chou-fleur n'était pas
hyper populaire non plus.
"Je vais vous servir
"un chou-fleur..."
-Ca faisait pas rêver,
dans l'assiette.
-C'était répulsif.
Maintenant,
un chou-fleur façon Ottolenghi,
ça se la pète un peu.
-Vous cuisinez à 80 ?
C'est pas facile de partager
la cuisine dans un groupe.
-Moi, j'aime bien
les tâches ingrates.
Je suis les petites mains.
J'épluche...
-Vous êtes la commis ?
-Voilà, je coupe,
je fais la vaisselle...
J'aime bien. Ca me va bien.
Je goûte.
Je dis si c'est assez salé,
pas assez salé.
-Vous avez aussi
des origines marocaines.
Les tajines, les couscous,
est-ce que vous en faites ?
Une recette familiale ?
-J'ai un problème,
c'est que j'aimais le beurre
quand j'étais petite
et j'en ai un peu abusé.
J'aime plus tellement
manger gras.
-Ah oui ?
-Je fais un couscous light,
qui déprime mon père.
Il est beaucoup trop light
pour être un vrai couscous homologué
couscous familial Aram.
Donc, voilà,
je m'arrange un peu avec tout ça.
Par exemple, le dimanche soir,
on n'a pas envie de cuisiner,
pas envie de...
Un petit tajine
avec de la sauce tomate,
je fais des boulettes de viande
pour mon fils...
Moi, je mange pas de viande.
On casse des oeufs dans la sauce,
et c'est délicieux.
C'est super bon,
et ça sent bon dans la maison,
les oignons, tout ça.
-La cannelle, parfois ?
Vous n'aimez pas ?
-J'adore la cannelle, mais pas là.
-Le rfissa,
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure,
comment ça se prononce ?
-Rfissa. Rfissa.
-Ca va pas, Jean-Pierre.
-Non, rfissa.
-Mais il y a pas de voyelle.
-Et alors ?
-C'est un plat familial,
qu'on sert aux femmes
qui ont eu un bébé.
C'est une tradition.
Les lentilles, c'est bon
quand on allaite.
Donc, on le sait,
il y a aussi toute cette science-là,
mais c'est une tradition.
Alors, c'est fait
avec les galettes marocaines
que l'on sert
au petit-déjeuner, au Maroc,
enfin, qu'on trouve partout
au Maghreb, oui.
On les découpe
en petits morceaux dans un plat,
et le bouillon est fait
à base d'oignons,
plein d'épices,
des lentilles
et du poulet,
et on sert tout ça
sur les galettes coupées.
-On peut aussi
en manger dans certains
restaurants marocains ?
-C'est très rare,
c'est vraiment un plat familial.
J'ai trouvé, du côté...
Du côté de Pasteur,
il y a une petite cantine,
j'ai oublié le nom,
ça me reviendra,
je vous l'enverrai pour le site,
où ils font des brunchs
avec ça, c'est génial.
Il faut peut-être pas
que je le dise.
-Il y aura trop de monde ?
-Ouais.
-Vous le préparez à la maison ?
-Je sais le faire.
Mon mari a appris à le faire.
Il le fait.
-D'accord, mais vous, sans poulet,
du coup ?
-Ca me dérange pas qu'il y ait
du poulet, mais j'en mange pas.
-Ca peut être cuit avec...
-Oui...
-Oui, non.
-Vous allez pas
jusque-là ?
-Je mange juste pas de viande.
-On va voir si vous êtes incollable.
C'est le quiz.
-Ouh !
-Alors, Sophia,
ayant vécu à Trappes,
vous avez été une Trappiste,
nom donné aux habitants,
mais aussi à des moines.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
sur l'alimentation
par le passé des moines
sont vraies ou fausses ?
"Par le passé",
parce qu'il y a eu des évolutions.
-Pour la A, je dirais que oui.
-Non, faux. Au fil du temps,
les moines avaient tellement envie
de boire
qu'on leur a permis de mettre
un peu de vin coupé avec de l'eau.
Le 100 % vin, c'était prohibé.
-Mais ils sont connus
pour la bière !
-Alors...
Non, non, mais c'est vrai,
bonne réflexion.
Ils ont eu le droit
de boire des bières.
On pensait que ça pouvait permettre
de ne pas user trop d'eau,
mais le vin était proscrit
au départ.
Affirmation suivante.
-Je vais dire oui.
-Oui, vrai. C'était des protéines.
Il fallait les donner aux malades.
Il n'y en avait pas assez.
Les moines se nourrissaient
de leur jardin.
Il n'y avait pas assez de bêtes
pour les nourrir.
-Pourquoi pas ?
-Oui, c'est vrai !
-Ca rejoint ce que je viens de dire.
S'il y avait un étang
près du monastère, ils pouvaient.
Ils étaient loin de la mer,
donc pas de poisson.
Affirmation suivante.
-Ben oui...
-Ben oui, eh oui, pourquoi pas ?
-C'est pas foufou, comme truc.
C'est très bon, les herbes.
-Les herbes cuites !
Deuxième quiz.
Un de vos anciens spectacles
s'appelait "La crise de foi".
-Aïe.
-Sans E.
-Oui, sans E, foi.
-A table,
on risque la crise de "foie".
Sauriez-vous nous dire
ce qui est conseillé
en cas de troubles ?
Elle rit.
Le radis noir, oui ou non ?
-Oui !
-Oui. Eh oui, le radis noir.
-Très, très bon.
Très, très bon.
-Très connu.
Le pain ?
-Non.
-Non, pas le pain.
-Elle est forte,
Sophia Aram.
-Je suis très santé, moi.
-Alors, là...
Le coca ?
-Alors, le coca...
On rentre dans les détails ?
Après une gastro, c'est recommandé,
mais sans les bulles.
-C'est ça.
Donc, c'est non.
C'est oui et non ?
-Pas de soda, pas de sucre.
-Mais le coca peut faire du bien.
-Je me demande si ce n'est pas
un mythe, après la gastro.
-Ca fait du bien.
-Ca rassure !
-C'est plus pour la réhydratation.
-La caféine peut remuscler,
alors qu'on est faible.
-On évite la gastro.
-Dernier aliment, l'asperge.
Est-ce que c'est conseillé
en cas de troubles, l'asperge ?
-J'ai jamais entendu ça,
je dirais non.
-J'aurais dit comme vous,
mais c'est oui.
-Ah oui ? Je vais la rajouter
dans ma liste.
-On peut le rajouter
pour la prochaine crise de foie.
-Une soupe d'asperges,
c'est très bien.
-Je ne sais si le kombucha
est conseillé en cas
de crise de foie.
C'est votre demande.
C'est une boisson
qui est fermentée,
à base de thé acidulé,
finement pétillante,
sans alcool, bien sûr,
bio, et on peut en trouver
de différentes saveurs.
Thé vert, thé noir,
"ginger", gingembre,
agrumes, framboise, citron...
Là, c'est au thé vert,
ça vous plaît ?
-Il est très bon,
celui-là.
-Vous en buvez beaucoup ?
-Oui, j'aime bien,
mais parce que...
J'aime pas l'alcool.
Je bois pas par goût,
je trouve ça pas bon en goût.
En soirée, souvent,
c'est pénible,
quand on dit
qu'on n'aime pas l'alcool.
J'arrive avec ma bouteille
de kombucha,
et ça me donne
une consistance d'adulte.
J'ai un verre avec un truc
qui a la couleur d'un whisky.
-C'est un peu comme
dans "Le père Noël est une ordure".
-J'ai ma bouteille.
-Que pour vous.
-Que pour moi.
C'est un truc qui questionne.
Quand on dit qu'on ne boit pas,
les gens vous regardent tristement.
-"Et tu ne manges pas de viande."
-"Pauvre petite.
Ta vie doit être très triste."
-Ca, vous le buvez en fête
pour faire la maline, mais à table,
on peut en boire ?
-A table, je bois de l'eau,
ou j'aime bien des boissons chaudes.
Je bois des infusions...
Vous avez fait des yeux bizarres.
-L'infusion à... à table ?
-Il a pas réussi à garder
son "poker face".
-Quelle tristesse !
-Boire une "nuit calme"
en mangeant...
un risotto, ça me paraît...
assez étonnant.
-Ca me dérange pas.
-Le côté asiatique ?
-J'aime l'eau chaude !
Elles rient.
Ces phrases qui, retirées
de leur contexte, sont si bizarres !
"J'aime l'eau chaude."
-Sous la douche,
oui, mais à table ?
-A table,
plutôt de l'eau.
-Mais ça, honnêtement,
on a l'impression
de se faire du bien.
Ca doit être bon
après une crise de foie.
-"C'est pas bon ?
Ca doit être bon pour la santé."
J'ai senti ça
dans la remarque.
-Non, pas du tout.
-C'est souvent autour
de la table, que se racontent
les meilleures histoires,
que se nouent, parfois,
des deals politiques.
La brève de comptoir.
Sofia Aram, on vous a demandé
de réfléchir
à une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas ou autre.
Laquelle vous avez envie
de raconter ?
-Politique,
j'avais pas.
Donc je me suis dit que,
comme on parlait
de nourriture...
Souvent, quand on me demande
ce que je mange,
ce que je mange pas,
je suis obligée
de faire une liste.
J'ai découvert
que j'avais des allergies.
Avant de le savoir, j'avais mangé
chez des amis, à Saint-Malo,
du crabe.
J'avais trouvé ça très bon,
j'en avais déjà mangé.
On s'était régalés !
Et en fin de repas,
tout à coup, mes paupières
se sont mises à enfler,
mon nez s'est mis à enfler,
ma bouche s'est mise à enfler,
et les gens me regardaient...
Vous voyez,
dans "Les 4 Fantastiques",
l'homme de pierre ?
Ca donnait ça,
j'avais le visage
granuleux.
Je me suis mise à suffoquer,
et on a compris que c'était
assez grave.
J'ai fait un oedème de Quincke
en arrivant aux urgences.
Il y avait tellement de monde !
J'ai eu envie
de faire demi-tour.
L'infirmier de garde m'a aperçue,
m'a attrapée et m'a emmenée
dans un box.
J'ai découvert à cette occasion-là
qu'un truc que j'aimais vraiment...
A l'époque, je mangeais des fruits
de mer et j'aimais le crabe.
On m'a dit qu'il ne fallait pas
que j'en mange,
et j'ai développé
un tas d'allergies.
Quand je dois dire aux gens
ce que je ne mange pas,
donc je ne mange pas de viande,
pas de crabe, pas de langouste,
pas de langoustines
et il y a un autre truc,
et j'ai oublié quoi.
C'est pas bien d'oublier.
-Les coquillages et tout ça,
vous ne mangez pas ?
Les Saint-Jacques ?
-Alors ça, ça va.
J'aime bien parce que...
les crevettes grises,
ça ne va pas fort,
alors que les crevettes, oui.
Allez savoir pourquoi.
Et par exemple,
tout ce qui est huître, non.
Quand c'est cru, non.
C'est pas l'iode.
-C'est intéressant.
Vous avez fait des tests ?
-Je suis allée
voir un allergologue.
Exactement.
-Qui a pu décrire tous les aliments.
-Et après,
j'ai fait des tests.
J'ai toujours de l'adrénaline
et de quoi me faire des piqûres :
je fais aussi des allergies
à des médicaments.
La fille hyper chiante
dans la vie.
-Il y a peut-être
encore des aliments
que vous ne soupçonnez pas.
-Et en plus,
on peut développer
des allergies plus tard.
-C'est terrible.
-Et une allergie,
c'est pour la vie ?
-Non, c'est arrivé tard
et ça peut partir.
-Vous ne voulez pas
en remanger, j'imagine ?
-Jouez,
on peut se marrer. Il faut filmer,
il peut y avoir un truc.
-Justement, on a du crabe pour vous.
-Mais le crabe, avant,
vous en mangiez,
et ça s'est déclaré à Saint-Malo.
C'est bizarre, non ?
-Rien à voir avec Saint-Malo.
-Bien sûr,
mais pourquoi ?
-Les convives ?
-Non plus.
-La variété du crabe ?
La quantité ? La mayonnaise ?
-Non, je suis allergique.
Maintenant,
si vous me faites
des pâtes au crabe,
que vous me dites :
"Non, y en a pas,
c'était à part",
et que ça a touché, je vais faire
une réaction allergique.
-Donc c'est grave.
-Oui,
c'est pas juste :
"Oui, c'est rigolo à voir".
-Pour les autres.
-Moi, je rigole moins.
En revanche, j'ai mangé du homard
et je ne suis pas allergique.
-Le homard, ça passe.
-C'est dingue !
C'est dingue.
-Donc homard à tous les repas,
-La fille qui coûte cher.
-Le caviar, ça va aussi ?
-J'en ai goûté
très, très tardivement et...
-C'est bien passé ?
-Oui, pareil,
avec l'adrénaline à côté,
je me suis dit :
"Pourvu que j'aime pas ça",
et j'ai trouvé ça bon
et j'ai pas fait d'allergie.
-Alors on continue.
-Vous savez
quoi m'offrir,
si vous voulez me faire plaisir.
-A Paris, il y a des restaurants
pas comme les autres :
le plus important n'est pas
forcément dans l'assiette.
On vous emmène
passer la soirée
au Paname Art Café.
Dans ce resto parisien,
la carte est variée
et surtout faite maison.
Mais si on y vient,
c'est aussi pour rire.
Après le dîner,
la soirée continue :
place au stand-up
dans ce comedy club
où se produisent comiques en herbe
comme les plus réputés.
Un reportage de Dario Borgonio
et Marion Devauchelle.
*-Le Paname,
faites-moi du bruiiiiit !
Acclamations
-Bienvenue
au Paname Art Café. Ici,
plus besoin de choisir
entre rire et manger.
D'un côté, les cuisines...
*-19h...
-Et de l'autre,
une scène mythique
du stand-up parisien.
Le concept : avant le spectacle,
un menu complet fait maison.
-Alors, les entrées.
-Je vais prendre le gravlax.
-On fait le repas avant
pour ne pas déranger
les humoristes,
puisque les gens
ne sont pas concentrés
sur les blagues,
mais sur l'assiette.
D'abord, le restaurant.
Après, la rigolade.
On rit plus le ventre plein.
-On mange super bien.
C'est super bon,
et c'est cool d'enchaîner
sur une soirée
un peu tranquille en semaine
et d'aller voir
un spectacle d'humoristes.
C'est pas tous les jours
que ça arrive.
Toutes les trois, on était d'accord
pour vivre ça ce soir.
Oui, je pense qu'on va bien
se marrer. Il y a des chances.
-Et pour réussir
à les faire rire,
sous leurs pieds,
dans les loges, les artistes
finalisent leur sketch.
-Je vais tester un petit truc.
C'est sur le racisme.
-Contrairement à son public,
l'humoriste est sur scène
le ventre vide.
-Parce que je joue avec mes tripes
et ça va se mélanger.
Donc je mange après.
Quand tu fais une scène
et que ça marche très, très bien,
T'es heureux, tu manges.
Sauf si tu bides...
Tu manges aussi.
-Vous allez adorer :
foutez-moi un bordel pour Lotfi !
Du bruit, du bruit !
Applaudissements
...
*-Ma première évaluation
en langue française,
le mec m'a félicité :
"Tu parles super bien italien,
"mon frère.
Continue comme ça".
*-Refaites-moi du bruit
pour Lotfi Abdelli !
-Après l'heure de spectacle,
les humoristes
se retrouvent enfin à table
pour découvrir une carte
sans cesse renouvelée.
-Ils font des efforts, comme nous :
on essaye d'améliorer nos sketchs
et ça s'améliore
parce qu'il y a plein de clients
qui viennent
spécialement manger ici.
Le Paname, ça devient un nom
donc ils ne peuvent pas se permettre
d'avoir une cuisine approximative.
C'est toujours pointu comme cuisine.
-Depuis son lancement en 2008,
le Paname a vu
des concurrents ouvrir
avec la même formule,
mais avec d'autres
éclats de rire.
Ils rient.
-Vous connaissez
le Paname Art Café ?
Vous y avez joué ?
-Non, mais je connais,
bien sûr. C'est un nom
qu'on connaît bien.
J'y suis jamais allée,
mais il a l'air d'y avoir
une super ambiance.
-Ca a l'air sympa.
Vous avez déjà joué
dans des petites salles comme ça ?
-J'ai démarré dans un bar.
Les gens buvaient des bières.
On jouait gratuitement
et on faisait passer un chapeau.
-Pour avoir un peu de sous.
-Et payer le régisseur
ou la régisseuse.
Quand on démarre...
-Les gens mangeaient là ?
-Oui, il y avait même des gens
derrière le rideau
qui fêtaient le match de rugby.
Oui, c'était folklorique.
-C'est difficile de se concentrer ?
-C'est formateur.
Vraiment, c'est formateur.
Je trouve que c'est
des conditions...
Surtout au début,
on est en insécurité,
et à la fois, si on arrive
à esquisser des rires,
à avoir des rires dans le public,
c'est qu'on a réussi
quelque chose.
-Les gens sont tout près.
Vous les voyez.
Si la vanne fait un bide,
vous le voyez tout de suite.
-Oui,
mais c'est très juste,
et à la fois, les gens qui mangent,
il y a des cabarets,
des choses comme ça.
Ca a toujours existé. Moi, j'avoue
que sur mes spectacles,
je ne trouve pas que ça s'y prête,
mais je pense
que sur certains spectacles
où on n'a pas besoin à 100 %
d'avoir un public trop captif,
ça peut se faire.
-Ca peut se faire.
-Vous avez fait
du vrai stand-up
où on raconte sa vie
à la première personne ?
-Non.
-C'était plus des sketches écrits.
-Mon premier spectacle,
c'était
un huis clos
dans une maternelle.
Je jouais tous les personnages
d'une cellule
de soutien psychologique...
Oui.
Vous avez un...
une communication non-verbale
avec un visage hyper expressif.
Ils rient.
Vous m'avez fait :
"Oh ouais. Oh ouais..."
-On me l'a jamais dit.
-Vous n'avez pas vu
ce spectacle ?
-Jim Carrey.
-Il vous faut
les contrechamps sur vous,
s'il vous plaît.
-Alors bon... Il a raison,
le comique ?
Mieux vaut monter
sur scène le ventre vide ?
-Moi, c'est toujours le cas.
Déjà, on n'a pas envie
d'avoir un rototo, d'avoir
un truc en travers
de la gorge,
ou d'avoir un truc
qu'on ne digère pas.
Non, puis même,
il y a une question de légèreté.
Je bois beaucoup
d'infusion d'eau chaude avant.
-Ca donne envie
d'aller aux toilettes.
-Oui, mais c'est pas grave.
Ca dure 1h30, le spectacle,
et on y va après,
mais il faut boire beaucoup
et manger après.
-Et on a faim après ou pas ?
Ca dépend de comment
ça s'est passé ?
-On a faim plus tard,
on a faim bien plus tard.
Mais si, on a quand même faim,
c'est ce que dit l'humoriste
dans le sketch :
"Quand on a fait un bide,
"on mange pour se rassurer,
et quand c'était bien,
"on mange pour se récompenser."
-Vous êtes friande
de cet art du stand-up ?
Le Paname Art Café,
le Jamel Comedy Club...
-Oui, mais c'est ancien.
-Beaucoup d'artistes sont...
-Beaucoup
d'artistes sont sortis
de là, oui, bien sûr.
Oui, si, c'est bien.
Bien sûr.
C'est chouette.
Je ne suis pas cliente.
Je ne vais pas...
-Mais vous n'allez pas voir
vos "collègues",
j'ai envie de dire ?
-On est pas confrères. Il n'y a pas
une famille des humoristes.
-C'est très hétéroclite.
-Puis on est seuls en scène.
-Oui mais vous vous reconnaissez,
si vous vous côtoyez ?
Il n'y a pas
une petite affinité ?
-Il pourrait,
mais on ne se voit pas, de fait,
sauf quand on fait des comedy clubs
où on est ensemble.
Je n'ai pas beaucoup connu ça,
à l'époque
où j'ai démarré,
où on faisait ces bars.
Il y avait Camille Chamoux
à l'époque,
il y avait des gens
qu'on ne voit plus.
Oui mais bon...
-Vous avez commencé
avec Jamel Debbouze aussi ?
-C'était l'improvisation théâtrale
au lycée à Trappes.
-Il y a des vidéos
où on vous voit.
-On était petits.
-Tout petits, déjà.
-C'était en 91.
-Les Trappistes.
-Omar Sy, Anelka...
-Alors Omar Sy,
il n'avait pas fait
d'impro. Il a démarré
avec Jamel plus tard.
Anelka, il a fait du foot.
-Oui, oui.
-Moi aussi.
-C'est une figure
emblématique de Trappes.
-J'ai fait du foot
mais je n'ai pas fait carrière.
-Bah ouais, vous auriez pu.
-Bah non.
Non, non.
-Alors "Le Monde d'après",
c'est une critique
des complotistes,
des antivax, des wokistes,
des extrêmes.
On écoute la bande annonce
et on en parle après.
*Musique raï dynamique
*...
Applaudissements
-Il y a des racisées dans la salle.
Je suis hyper contente.
Il y a plein de racisés,
on les a mis devant.
Je suis trop contente
que vous soyez là.
Namasté.
Le public rit.
Euh, coeur sur vous
et vagin avec les doigts.
Par exemple, à chaque fois
que je vais chez la gynéco,
la seule question à laquelle
j'ai toujours droit, c'est :
"Et alors ?
Elle est sympa Léa Salamé ?"
...
Si tous ceux
qui se foutent de leur gueule
suçaient vraiment Macron,
Macron, il lui resterait
plus que des copeaux, hein.
Vous remarquerez que ça ne marche
qu'avec l'extrême droite.
Jamais personne
ne vous reprochera de faire
le jeu du MoDem,
par exemple.
...
Ségolène Royal, elle a quand même
toujours été à la politique
ce que la sodomie
est à la reproduction :
divertissante...
mais totalement inutile.
Est-ce qu'on peut rire
de la gauche ?
...
Les gens de droite,
taisez-vous.
...
-Qu'est-ce qui vous agace
le plus, finalement...
-Ouh là.
-...dans ce monde
d'après ?
-La liste est longue.
Je sais pas
par quoi commencer.
Oh, en ce moment,
je dirais la lâcheté,
peut-être,
et puis les délires,
je veux dire
les approximations,
le fait que les mots
n'aient plus de sens. Je continue ?
-Allez-y.
-Ben non, mais c'est
une accumulation de choses.
Ces dernières années, on a vu...
Enfin, je ne sais pas. Autrefois,
on débattait sereinement.
On pouvait avoir des arguments
qui étaient fondés.
Aujourd'hui,
balancez quelque chose de faux,
et si vous démontrez
que c'est faux,
c'est pas grave.
Il suffit que l'autre
en soit convaincu
pour que ça soit légitime.
C'est quand même
assez terrible.
Puis toute la culture
de la victimisation...
On est dans une époque du ressenti.
Le ressenti compte plus que tout.
Tout ça, ça m'agace.
-Cette défense
des minorités, ça vous agace ?
-Moi, les minorités,
j'ai toujours défendu.
C'est pas une défense des minorités,
c'est les discriminations,
les inégalités, tout ça, oui.
-Les injustices.
Pour moi,
c'est tellement évident.
Mais il y a une façon
de traiter ça. Aujourd'hui,
les personnes
qui se disent "antiracistes"
confondent l'antiracisme et la WWF.
J'ai l'impression qu'on considère
les minorités comme
des petites choses fragiles.
C'est insupportable.
-Il y a une espèce
d'archipellisation ?
-Oui, en plus.
C'est assez pénible :
il va falloir
défendre... Qu'on défende
les LGBT d'un côté,
qu'on défende
les musulmans de l'autre,
les handicapés d'un côté,
les femmes de l'autre,
mais sans volonté universelle
et moi, je suis
assez universaliste
et je pense qu'on peut
s'approprier tout ce combat.
-Certains disent que vous êtes
de droite. Ca vous agace ?
Est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
devenue réac, à vous dire :
"Tous ces gens-là, ça m'énerve.
Tout ça, ça m'agace" ?
-Je ne pense pas être de droite.
En fait, ce que je dis, c'est que...
C'est souvent la LFI
qui me fait ce procès.
De toute façon,
tout ce qui est
à la droite de LFI
est d'extrême droite.
Aujourd'hui, les lignes,
pour eux, c'est ça.
Moi, je n'ai pas bougé d'un poil,
je suis toujours la même
et je pense être de gauche,
être social-démocrate,
mais aujourd'hui, quand on dit
qu'on est social-démocrate...
-Et laïque,
et républicaine.
-Laïque, républicaine,
féministe,
écolo : je suis sensible
aux questions environnementales,
comme beaucoup, et voilà.
Donc oui, je suis assez de gauche.
-Vous parliez
de post-vérité, d'archipellisation.
Est-ce que l'humour peut être
un ciment ou une arme
pour lutter contre les fake news,
contre la post-vérité ?
Ca peut aider ?
-C'est celle que j'ai choisie,
en me foutant de leur gueule.
Oui, je pense que c'en est une.
Après, la science doit être
réhabilitée par les scientifiques.
Il faut laisser les scientifiques
avancer et continuer la recherche
et continuer
de ne pas opposer...
des antivax à des scientifiques,
par exemple. Ca, ça pourrait aider.
Mais nous, humoristes,
on est dans notre rôle, oui,
quand on se fout
de leur gueule.
-Vous vous dites féministe,
mais vous vous moquez
aussi des féministes.
-C'est pas anti-féministe
que de se foutre de la gueule
de certaines
quand elles sont délirantes.
Oui, je peux me foutre
de leur gueule.
-Il y en a beaucoup
qui sont "délirantes" ?
-Ca peut aller très loin.
Je pense que la caricature,
l'excès de certaines
est contreproductif.
C'est ce que je raconte.
Je pense qu'il faut continuer
d'être féministe
pour avoir l'égalité salariale,
et réduire les féminicides
dans ce pays.
Il faut se battre,
mais est-ce qu'on prend
les bonnes armes ?
-Etre excessif,
ça ne peut pas faire
avancer la cause ?
-Je crois. Je ne sais pas,
c'est pas l'excès,
parce que les excès,
ça a été nécessaire.
En 68, il a fallu
qu'il y ait des propos excessifs,
des mouvements excessifs,
mais l'excès peut aussi...
Surtout quand on est dans un corner
dans lequel on s'enferme.
L'enfermement est dangereux,
empêcher les autres de parler aussi.
Interdire à un homme
de parler du féminisme.
Je pense qu'on a besoin des hommes
dans cette lutte-là.
-Alors, Ségolène Royal ?
-Oui.
-Pourquoi Ségolène Royal ?
-Mais on l'a perdue,
Ségolène Royal, c'est...
C'est vertigineux.
On n'avait peut-être pas vu avant,
mais ses prises de position...
Elle a quand même contesté
le bombardement
de la maternité de Marioupol
en disant : "On ne sait pas."
Donc, dans la post-vérité,
là, on est à fond.
Elle est devenue chroniqueuse
chez Hanouna, voilà.
Elle est pro-russe.
-Donc, inutile, pour vous ?
-Ah oui,
il faut arrêter, quoi.
-On a l'impression
que vous êtes plus anti-insoumis
qu'anti-Rassemblement National.
Vous vous trompez pas de cible ?
-Ah non, non, non, non, non !
Qu'on ne se trompe pas.
En plus, l'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
J'ai toujours combattu
l'extrême droite,
mais toujours.
J'ai commencé, à la radio,
à les combattre frontalement,
Jean-Marie Le Pen,
Marine Le Pen
et les électeurs
du Rassemblement National
en 2011.
Ca m'a coûté assez cher.
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
ce matin encore,
je suis allée bloquer
ceux qui me proposent
de me mettre des saucissons
dans le derrière.
Eux, ils se trompent pas.
Ils savent très bien
que je les cible.
En revanche,
ça ne m'empêchera jamais
d'attaquer les insoumis
quand ils refusent de dire
que le Hamas est
une organisation terroriste,
quand ils refusent de prendre
des positions claires,
quand ils font du tort
à la gauche,
quand ils ont des positions
qui ne sont pas claires
sur l'antisémitisme.
Il faut être clair.
Quand des gens
qui se disent de gauche
ne le sont pas,
sur Poutine,
sur les vaccins,
enfin, sur tellement de sujets...
La liste est tellement longue
que je ne me priverai jamais
de les combattre.
C'est pas parce que l'extrême droite
est puissante aujourd'hui
que je dois m'interdire
de combattre La France Insoumise.
Je continue de combattre
l'extrême droite, de mon côté.
C'est très clair.
Les deux ne sont pas incompatibles.
On peut combattre les deux.
-Vous qualifier
d'humoriste politique,
ça vous convient ?
-Ouais.
-Ca vous va ?
Vous avez jamais eu envie
de vous engager ?
Vous êtes très engagée
dans vos spectacles.
Faire de la politique ?
-Non.
Je dis "ouais", "non",
des réponses hyper pénibles.
Non. Je fais des spectacles
dans lesquels
j'arrive à dire
plein de choses.
Je suis pas sûre que j'aurais
la même liberté si j'étais...
Ca m'a jamais effleuré l'esprit,
je suis très bien là où je suis.
J'ai beaucoup de respect
pour l'engagement politique
et tout ça.
-Il n'y a jamais
des politiques
qui sont venus vous chercher
en vous disant :
"Viens pour ma campagne" ?
-Si, ils pensent que c'est possible,
mais je veux pouvoir
leur taper dessus aussi.
-C'est votre indépendance ?
-Ma liberté totale, oui.
-Pardon. Jean-Pierre ?
-Juste une petite question.
Je ne parle plus
du spectacle,
mais de ce monde d'après.
Comment vous le voyez ?
Vous êtes pessimiste ?
-Pas foufou. On n'est pas au top...
-Il y en a qui se donnent
des raisons d'espérer.
Il y a des livres
qui sortent.
-Moi, j'ai un autre livre,
c'était un roman
de Shalom Auslander, qui s'appelle
"L'espoir, cette tragédie".
Je pense que les optimistes
sont des gens dangereux.
Je suis assez d'accord
avec Shalom Auslander.
Non, je suis pas très optimiste,
mais je suis combative.
Voilà.
-Mais en combattant,
on peut retrouver de l'espoir.
-Voilà,
mais pour l'instant, on sent
que c'est pas complètement gagné.
Des raisons de se réjouir
aujourd'hui, il y en a pas moult.
-Peut-être demain...
-A part un bon plat
de pâtes à la sauce tomate !
-Vous parliez
de lâcheté
au début de vos propos.
Vous avez dénoncé
le silence des artistes.
Souvent, on dit : "Finalement,
pourquoi ils se mêlent de ça ?
"Est-ce qu'un footballeur
doit vraiment avoir
"un engagement ?"
Est-ce qu'être artiste,
un personnage public,
ça donne forcément
le droit de s'exprimer
ou ça a forcément envie
de tenir un message politique ?
-C'est vraiment
la liberté de chacun
et j'impose à personne
de s'exprimer.
J'ai dit qu'il y avait
des personnalités qui sont réputées
pour signer des tribunes
à longueur de journée.
Celles-ci, on les a pas entendues
après le 7 octobre,
et j'ai trouvé ça dommage.
J'ai trouvé ça triste
et j'ai trouvé ça inquiétant
Je l'ai dit
parce qu'on m'a posé la question.
Je suis pas allée faire
une tribune
pour le dire.
On m'a posé la question,
j'ai répondu.
Sinon, je ne serais pas allée
leur dire : "Allez-y !"
Je pense que
quand la situation est grave...
Enfin, je sais pas,
j'imaginais
que ce qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre
était suffisamment grave
pour que ça crée
un électrochoc mondial.
-Vous attendez.
-Il y a pas eu.
Mais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui...
La situation en Palestine
est tellement grave aussi
qu'il faut aussi le dénoncer.
L'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
C'est dommage.
Je pense qu'il y a
des personnes
qui pourraient apaiser
la situation,
en France, en tout cas.
-Alors là,
on a besoin de se rassurer.
On va s'accrocher
à notre plat de pâtes.
On va revenir
à l'alimentation.
Vous êtes plus de 2 %
à être végétariens,
comme vous.
Ca veut dire
qu'en France, on mange encore
beaucoup de produits carnés,
qu'on retrouve à la carte
des restaurants.
Un casse-tête pour les anti-viande.
On en parle.
-Brigitte,
dans ce restaurant,
Faubourg Daimant,
on y mange des rillettes,
des croquettes,
mais, amis carnivores,
vous faites fausse route.
Toutes ces recettes sont
sans viande, donc végétales,
mais avec un mantra :
la gourmandise.
C'est un reportage non carné
d'Elsa Mondin-Gava
et Elzéar Le Gonidec.
-Là, on prépare
les croquettes cochonnes.
Les ingrédients,
ça va être des champignons de Paris,
des champignons crème,
et du tofu fumé.
Ensuite, il y a
des échalotes confites
et un petit bouillon
qui est mis en gelée
pour pouvoir lier le tout.
-Eh oui !
Dans ces croquettes cochonnes,
il n'y a du cochon
que dans le nom.
Dans ce restaurant,
pas de viande, pas de poisson,
rien qui vient de l'animal.
Tout est végétal,
mais pas fade.
Assaisonnement,
sauces, cuisson...
Un mot d'ordre :
la gourmandise.
-Il faut qu'on ait
une certaine texture en bouche,
comme un peu un pied de cochon,
mais que ce soit
très gourmand, très régressif,
mais en végétal.
-Alors ?
-Excellent !
-Excellent, pour le chef.
Alors, allons vérifier en salle.
-Les croquettes cochonnes
avec la sauce ravigote.
-Ca a vraiment
un goût très fumé, très prononcé.
On a vraiment l'impression
de manger de la viande,
mais il y a rien du tout,
il y a que des légumes.
-Est-ce que c'est bon ?
-Délicieux.
-Benoît et Marie apprécient
cette cuisine végane,
eux qui veulent réduire
leur consommation de viande.
Sur la carte,
à côté des croquettes,
un carpaccio
de céleri ou des rillettes
de lentilles.
Le but : rassurer le client
avec des références connues.
-On a tous les codes du bistrot.
C'est ça que je trouve intéressant.
Même dans la façon...
Avec le mot "rillettes",
tout de suite, on pense
à de la viande et c'en est pas.
Il y a un peu
des trompe-l'oeil intéressants
dans ces plats,
sur la façon dont c'est abordé.
-Proposer une cuisine durable,
mais gourmande,
c'est l'objectif
d'Alice Tuyet.
-C'est vrai qu'on peut avoir
cette image de la cuisine végétale
qui est très restrictive,
ascétique, un peu tristoune,
enfin, cuisine de régime,
alors qu'on peut faire vraiment
de la bonne bouffe
avec de la sauce,
avec du gras, avec des textures,
avec plein de techniques
de cuisson.
On cherche cet effet de surprise
chez les clients.
Nous, en tant que restaurateurs,
une de nos obligations,
c'est de rendre désirable
cette durabilité.
Ca passe par cette cuisine-là,
qui est bien plus hédoniste
que ce qu'on pense.
-En France,
150 restaurants servent
des menus exclusivement
végétariens ou végans.
-Alors, Sophia,
une petite envie de goûter
une croquette cochonne ?
-Dit comme ça...
-Allez.
-Je suis joueuse.
-Nous, on est joueurs ici.
Brigitte ? Allez ?
-Allez.
Merci, hein !
Oh là là !
-Si, c'est bon.
-Oui.
-C'est du cochon sans halouf.
-C'est ça.
-Mais c'est vrai
que, j'y croyais pas trop
en écoutant le reportage,
ils restituent assez bien
le goût de la viande
alors qu'il y a du tofu
et des champignons.
-Vous trouvez ?
-Ben, je trouve.
A l'aveugle,
je me serais fait avoir.
Alors, ça vaut pas
un bon pied de cochon pané,
mais je trouve
que c'est assez gourmand.
-Quel enfer,
le pied de cochon pané !
-Est-ce que le fait de garder
des noms carnés, "rillettes",
"croquettes", qui font appel
à des produits carnés,
c'est une bonne idée,
pour vous, végétarienne ?
-Tout dépend de la raison
de votre végétarisme.
Si vous devenez végétarien
alors que vous aimez la viande,
j'imagine
que ça doit être un truc
de réconfort, d'aller rechercher
des saveurs ou des textures
qui vous rappellent quelque chose.
Moi, j'aime pas la viande.
-Mais vous, c'est par goût ?
-Oui.
-C'était depuis l'âge de 13 ans ?
-Oui, 13 ans.
Je peux le dater...
-Il y a eu un élément déclencheur ?
-Oui.
-Il y en a toujours.
-J'aimais pas ça, d'abord.
Ca a pas du tout été difficile.
J'en mangeais pas beaucoup,
j'aimais pas vraiment ça.
Puis, à l'Aïd, au Maroc,
mon grand-père égorge
le mouton
et tout se passe bien
dans la mesure du possible.
J'étais avec ma cousine
et mon grand-père.
J'ai dû mettre les mains à la pâte.
Donc, j'ai tout fait avec lui.
On a ramassé les abats,
on a nettoyé le sang,
avec ma cousine,
on a grillé
les pattes pas du cochon,
mais du mouton, et tout ça.
On a tout fait.
Après, quand ma cousine et moi,
on s'est posées
pour prendre les brochettes,
avec le thé à la menthe,
j'ai pas eu envie
d'en manger.
J'avais les yeux du mouton
un petit peu triste.
Le lendemain,
couscous avec le mouton et...
Non,
je n'avais pas eu envie.
Là, j'ai compris
que je n'en voulais plus
car je ne voulais plus avoir
à manger de viande, en fait.
-C'est plus
le bien-être animal,
la souffrance de la bête
qui vous a...
-Il y avait de ça.
J'ai eu un rapport à la bête
comme ça qui m'a...
Ca m'allait bien
de ne pas manger de viande.
J'étais en paix avec ça.
Je me suis dit que je voulais pas
en manger alors j'en mange pas.
J'ai fait attention,
j'essaye d'équilibrer.
Je mange encore un peu de poisson,
pour avoir un peu de protéines.
Je mange des oeufs...
-Vous êtes pas végétarienne.
-Comment on dit ?
-Flexitarienne.
-C'est quand on mange
de la viande.
Mais vous, c'est pas du tout ?
-C'est ça.
En revanche, je ne vais pas
chercher un truc
qui va ressembler
à de la viande.
J'ai pas envie d'aller manger
des côtelettes de tofu...
-Des rillettes
de je sais pas quoi.
Ca, ça vous fait pas
particulièrement envie ?
-Non,
ça m'excite pas beaucoup.
Mais je comprends si c'est quelqu'un
qui aimait la viande,
qui a arrêté
par conscience
de l'environnement
ou pour le bien-être animal
et qui se dit :
"J'aimais bien manger
des burgers."
-C'est pas le respect
du vivant,
votre histoire, car vous mangez
des poissons qui sont vivants.
Vous acceptez de les voir morts
dans votre assiette.
-Je les mange pas vivants.
-Non, mais vous acceptez
de les manger grillés,
des sardines...
-C'est compliqué d'équilibrer
son alimentation
sans avoir
de protéines animales.
Je mange des oeufs
et un peu de poisson.
Et... Ouais.
En fait, je sais...
Je les regarde pas
dans les yeux, les poissons,
quand je les vois
chez le poissonnier.
-Petite, il y avait des plats
à base de viande,
que ce soit le couscous, le tajine.
Ca posait
des problèmes
ou c'était accepté ?
-Ca en faisait plus pour les autres.
Mon père continue de me proposer
de la viande aujourd'hui
au cas où je change d'avis.
-Ca peut revenir.
-Il a pas capitulé.
-Il lâche pas l'affaire.
-Vous trouvez
que vous avez le choix
dans les restaurants ?
Quand on est végétarien aujourd'hui,
la carte est souvent un peu maigre.
Il y a pas toujours beaucoup de...
-Non,
on trouve toujours.
Quand je suis invitée quelque part,
je le dis pas.
J'aime pas le dire car j'aime pas
imposer une contrainte.
Après,
les gens se cassent la tête
alors qu'il suffit
de pousser la viande
et de manger les légumes.
Il y a toujours une solution.
-C'est pas très fun.
Vous vous tapez tous les légumes.
-C'est bien, les légumes.
Ca me dérange pas du tout.
C'est ma contrainte, j'aime pas
l'imposer aux autres.
Mon mari en a marre
qu'on mange végétarien
partout où on va,
en plus de la maison.
Quand il sort, il aime bien
avoir de la viande.
-Comme votre père,
il a espoir ?
-Il dit que ça peut arriver.
Surtout, il n'y a pas de dogmatisme
dans mon rapport à la viande.
Je veux pas que ce soit
une contrainte pour les autres.
A la carte, je trouve
toujours mon bonheur.
-Et les légumineuses ?
-J'adore
les lentilles.
-Vous compensez
le manque de protéine par ça ?
-Oui.
-Du quinoa aussi ?
-Le quinoa, c'est pareil,
c'est pas un truc foufou.
C'est plus pour remplacer le riz,
les pâtes et tout ça.
Mais non, les légumineuses,
surtout là,
avec l'entrée dans l'hiver,
j'adore ça.
-J'admire votre côté concilient
car je trouve que ça se radicalise.
Les végétariens ne font pas
de concessions.
Vous les invitez, si ça a touché
de la viande, ils n'en veulent pas.
A table, vous trouvez pas qu'il y a
une radicalité qui s'inscrit
comme en politique ou ailleurs ?
-Peut-être que c'est un passage.
On est en train de découvrir
ces problématiques-là.
On est en train d'en prendre
la mesure,
ça va peut-être se calmer.
C'est les jeunes
qui sont comme ça.
Les jeunes sont dans leur rôle
de nous bousculer,
de nous remuer sur...
-Pas toujours très cohérents,
les jeunes, qui peuvent dire non
à la viande et oui à la malbouffe.
-Exactement.
Mais est-ce qu'on est pas contents
que nos jeunes se mobilisent
sur ces sujets-là
et prennent conscience
là où nous, on n'a pas été
à la hauteur ?
C'est plutôt bien qu'ils s'emparent
de ces sujets-là.
Je pense que c'est aussi à nous
d'être un peu conciliant,
de faire un pas vers eux.
-C'est plus compliqué
la table aujourd'hui
entre végétarien,
végétalien, végan...
-SANS GLUTEN, SANS LACTOSE
ET LES ALLERGIQUES.
-C'est compliqué d'inviter les gens,
de se réunir.
-Si vous mangez
casher, hallal.
Si vous avez les allergies,
les intolérants
et les restrictions
religieuses...
Là... On n'est pas rendus.
-On ne s'en sort plus
alors que la table, c'est une façon
facile de se réunir.
Ca devient un peu plus touchy.
-Le plat de pâtes, c'est pas mal,
mais des pâtes sans gluten.
-Il y en a qui vont nous dire
que les tomates
sont pas de saison.
Il y a toujours un moyen
de discorde
alors que c'était fédérateur.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est diviseur.
-Je pense que, quand même,
on se retrouve.
On aime beaucoup manger.
On reste Français, on reste attachés
à la gastronomie.
Vous avez une émission
dans laquelle on mange,
ça dit quelque chose
sur notre rapport à la bouffe.
-On va passer au dessert.
-Ouais !
Il est arrivé.
Je l'ai vu.
-Voici le temps du sucré
avec un gâteau au chocolat.
Dans cette trilogie gourmande,
moelleux, fondant, mi-cuit,
on a droit à un moelleux.
Je sais pas si c'est celui
que vous aimez le plus.
Il faut bien savoir
que le moelleux
est le plus cuit.
Le fondant est encore moins cuit.
Le coulant est
encore moins, moins cuit.
Normalement, quand on l'ouvre,
il est coulant à coeur.
-Là, il est
bien peu coulant.
-On nous a vendu
un coulant...
-Un moelleux coulant.
-Un "moellant".
-Voilà.
-Est-ce qu'il est bon ?
Vous vouliez du chocolat,
mais surtout, vous aviez dit :
"Surtout pas de crème anglaise."
Vous n'aimez pas ?
-Non, ça gâche un peu.
-Vous aimez le chocolat pur ?
-Mais si, c'est bon.
Oui, la crème anglaise,
je vois pas l'intérêt.
Pourquoi mettre de la crème anglaise
sur les desserts ?
Les deux sont bons,
mais ensemble...
-Plutôt
sur l'île flottante ?
-Oui.
-Il y a dans modes, comme ça.
-Exactement.
Même le caramel,
je vois pas l'intérêt.
-Le chocolat,
vous l'aimez moelleux,
coulant, fondant ?
Vous mangez des carrés de chocolat ?
-J'ai une recette
de gâteau au chocolat mousse,
sans farine,
cuit au bain-marie.
C'est hyper bon.
On fait cuire une heure
au bain-marie.
-C'est entre le gâteau
et la mousse ?
-Oui, une mousse cuite.
-Ca se sert chaud ?
-Chaud,
avec de la crème fouettée,
pour le coup.
-J'ai cru qu'il y avait
de la crème anglaise.
-C'est cochon, comme dessert.
C'est que du sucre et du gras,
mais c'est bon.
-C'est le seul dessert
que vous mangez ?
-Le seul que je réussisse
à peu près à faire.
Non, j'en mange...
J'aime bien terminer
avec une petite note de sucre,
et le chocolat,
c'est tellement bon,
et ça apporte du réconfort.
-Vous faites de la pâtisserie
avec vos enfants ?
-J'ai un fils qui a 24 ans
et on faisait des gâteaux au yaourt
quand il était petit.
Le gâteau du dimanche.
-La première expérience
de pâtisserie
pour nous tous.
-C'est une valeur sûre.
-Et c'est pas difficile
à faire.
-C'est dans mes cordes,
je maîtrise parfaitement
le gâteau au yaourt.
Et dans ces trucs de réconfort,
j'aime l'odeur du gâteau
dans la maison le dimanche.
Il y a un truc qui va bien.
-Le truc de grand-mère.
-Oui, un truc avec un petit thé,
sous un plaid...
-Toujours le thé.
-La boisson chaude.
-Et les desserts
marocains, les baklawas...
(-Non, pas la baklawa.)
-C'est pas marocain ?
La boulette !
-La boulette, oui,
mais le baklawa, non.
-On n'en mange pas,
au Maroc, des baklawas ?
-On en mange... On mange des trucs
à base de miel et d'amande...
-Il me semblait
qu'on en trouvait.
-On mange des cornes de gazelle,
plein de sablés à base d'amande,
mais on les mange pas en dessert.
On les mange avec le thé.
-Plutôt au goûter ?
-Oui, à plusieurs moments
dans la journée : 10h, 11h...
Mais après le repas,
parfois, on va servir des fruits,
mais on mange pas de dessert.
On n'a pas cette...
-Culture comme en France.
-Non, et dans pas mal
de pays arabes,
le dessert, c'est pas...
C'est très européen.
-Les salades
d'orange, à la cannelle ?
-Ca, voilà.
-Il y a des pâtisseries
aux dattes, aussi,
qui sont bonnes au Maroc, non ?
-Les makrouds.
-Avec le petit sourire,
comme ça.
Ca a l'air bon.
-Il y a gros conflit
entre les Marocains
et les Tunisiens.
Les Tunisiens disent
qu'ils les font mieux.
Mais j'en ai mangés, à Kairouan,
qui étaient exceptionnels.
Et au Maroc, ils sont bons aussi.
Je veux pas fâcher.
Je veux fâcher personne.
Sur les pâtisseries,
on fâchera personne.
-On finit
en musique.
Vous avez choisi
celle-là.
*-I been wearin' my hoops
I been wearin' my big ol'
Silver hoops
I been walkin'
'Round the house in 'em babe
I been chillin'on the couch in 'em
I'm accenting with socks
I'm accenting with brightly
Colored socks
I been puttin' a show on for me
Babe
I'm the only one who knows it
It's whatever we feel
It's whatever
We wanna do
It's whatever we feel
Whatever
We wanna do
It's whatever...
-Alors qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette chanson ?
-Elle est pas magnifique ?
-Magnifique.
-J'aime beaucoup cette chanteuse,
Sammy Rae
& Friends,
c'est le nom du groupe.
Je suis tombée dessus
par hasard.
Là, l'orchestre démarre.
Et l'orchestre part avec...
Ca fout le feu,
ça met une patate d'enfer.
Je suis tombée dessus par hasard,
en mode de lecture aléatoire
sur ma playlist.
Et j'ai pris
son album, j'ai écouté
tout ce qu'elle fait,
et j'ai trouvé ça enthousiasmant.
Elle a 27,
28 ans.
-Dansant.
-Oui, c'est joyeux.
C'est la fête
avec l'orchestre,
la grosse fanfare.
-Au jour d'après ?
-Voilà.
-Un jour, on sera tous là
à faire la fête
et on appellera Sammy Rae.
Elle est bientôt sur scène,
le 14 novembre,
au Bataclan.
Je... Voilà,
il faut y aller.
-Excellent ?
-Elle est super.
-Merci.
-J'espère que ça plaira.
-Merci d'être venue.
-Merci,
c'était très bon.
Il a fini
son dessert.
-Merci à Chez Françoise,
qui nous a fourni ces bons plats.
Merci, Jean-Pierre.
Merci à vous de nous avoir suivis.
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine
sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
"Whatever We Feel",
Sammy Rae & The Friends
...